welcome back dimang figures today
revealed that obesity cost British
taxpayers almost 14 billion pounds a
year of these patients cost of British
Health Service twice as much as those of
a healthy weight but the body positivity
movement preaches that fat is now
fabulous and that is crazed is fat
fluences who rake in cash by posting
about well being fat
that's what I hear today is a fetch
let's go I don't know how many times I
have to tell you this is I'm going to
start my morning off at the Starbucks
iced coffee
[Music]
other Macy's and then I had a few
mouthfuls of this cake but it wasn't
oh yeah
[Music]
really that's what people are watching
apparently well Tick Tock is like my
next guest of putting the pound in
excess pounds the new hot dirty eye is
just
89.99 do you like sweets well you can
get two kilos of sweets for 10 pounds
promoting obesity no I'm promoting a
good deal 25.99 for 63 rolls of toilet
paper a donut maker from tower all of
these products have two year warranty a
candy floss maker and a chocolate
fountain
okay so I'm joined by Tick Tock star
George keyman who you just saw there and
see you again that's why I say Bargains
Bargas all right and his wife Sienna and
the host of The Blair White Project
Blair why okay listen uh Blair come to
you in a moment first of all all right
George let me guess some stats yeah if
you don't mind me asking how much do you
weigh look I'm not going to talk about
numbers because the thing is when you
well I think you should I mean the thing
is if I give you the number of how much
I weigh it's going to be all over the
sun all those trashy newspapers tomorrow
I don't need it don't need it you're on
you're on Tick Tock every day showing us
how big you are yeah and look and you're
proud of it no no no no no that's the
difference there's proud and then
there's just being positive in my own
skin and that's what I am right I'm not
I'm not proud to be fat would you accept
that by medical definition you are
morbidly obese look if that's what
medically you want to call it then call
it no you know your weight I don't know
but that's yeah could say that yeah
right so here's my issue with this body
positivity thing people shouldn't be
celebrating being morbidly obese in my
estimation but that's the because
actually it is a dangerous condition
that causes many people to die look
you've got a fair point it is dangerous
it can lead to dangerous issues which
could you know diabetes and so on and
that is an issue but we don't encourage
gaining weight there's a difference
between the videos you just showed on
the timer
no no you're in you're showing people
encouraging eating food I'm just saying
wow look at the pizza look it's from
Costco it's no no no you're not you're
not sorry you are glorifying glorifying
stuffing
that's what it is or maybe that's what
it is
why is it funny because it is funny you
know it is funny you have a lot about
yourself I actually don't find it funny
I think no come on I actually think it's
quite sad it's comedy let me bring it
well they know it is I you know it is I
know it is please I've been an actor for
13 years
Blair I do have a problem with this
because I think it's celebrating a
dangerous health condition and we and if
you're an influencer why would you want
to influence people to think that that
is a funny entertaining and be something
they want to do
well you should have an issue with it
you know my opinion is that the fat
positivity movement is a death cult you
know I'm all about living my life on my
own terms being happy finding a partner
that makes me happy but you know life is
short so you have to find happiness but
what cuts it in half is being obese your
life will literally end halfway of the
length that you would live being obese
and so promoting it you wouldn't be able
to be anorexic on Tick Tock and not get
comments about how you need to eat a
cheeseburger how you need to gain weight
and you can write it off as Trolls but
it's the truth you know I've seen some
tick tocks made by him where he is
addressing people telling him that he
needs to lose weight as trolls and sort
of making fun of it and I just wonder
you know is it really trolls I mean
certainly there are mean people on the
internet but there is some truth to it I
mean I know that he is a father and the
idea that you will in all likelihood and
all certainty actually not live past 50
60 years old is an issue so for me you
know okay yeah I know hey that's that's
my view I want to bring in Sienna your
wife you've been listening to this yeah
are you comfortable completely when you
see that the statistics about obesity in
this country the cost to the NHS what it
costs the country yeah are you
comfortable about this
the way I see it is firstly just us
personally
um where we have Private health care so
the NHS isn't a thing for us I do
understand that it is costing the NHS a
lot I think it's a bigger problem to
address though I think it's about
educating people when they're young to
make healthy food choices I think a lot
of the time when you grow up in poverty
like George and I have a lot of the time
you don't have the healthiest options
yeah but my response to that would be
okay but you've managed not to
end up as George has Weight Wise and I
don't mean to denigrate your jewelry
I don't think it's genetics no I I
believe it's because my parents were
like cool hippie vegetarians whereas um
Georges were not are you comfortable you
got us a son right are you comfortable
about his current weight do you think
when he when he does his stuff on Tick
Tock are you really laughing or are you
concerned about it I'm I'm concerned not
so much about his way but more about
um
his well-being and you know yeah no you
definitely glorify it Sienna and you
guys post videos where you're jiggling
his fat and you talk about how
attractive it is and for me
a better version of myself well yeah but
George but George the point the point
Blair's making is a sound one you say
it's to get views we know that and
you're making money from it of course
but the question is there's no incentive
for you to actually lose any weight
because of that stage your Tick Tock oh
no it's actually George is um actually
on a weight loss journey and I fully
support that I think it's more like
having a laugh at yourself making the
best of you know what made me you know
probably around to your side George if
you now flipped with this big audience
you've got and rather than gorging
yourself every day on pizzas and donuts
so that's not what I do people love you
why don't you actually go on a fitness
regime and show people how to lose
weight if people actually knew what I
was thinking and what I'm doing I'm
actually going to be doing it asemic
needles privately as well but before you
start so all of these things we're
paying out of our own money we're not
we're not we don't cost anyone anything
maybe you're making out of the tick tock
a lot of money like what a lot over 100
Grand over a year over 100 years so
there's no incentive to lose weight is
it no but it doesn't derive straight
from that that's from my sales and
that's with the collaborations
Are you ashamed of it
okay final word to you
I just don't know why he would come on a
panel discussing Weight and Body
positivity fat positivity and not okay
guys I'm sorry I ran out of time thank
you all of you very much today